hey today we're gonna do South Park in
real life a lot of you verse suggested
this one so I think it's gonna be good I
was thinking what should I use for the
stock I guess I'll just search like fat
kid there we have our lumpy little boy
ah let's let's start with a the shape of
the face yes that's a good appropriate
size already amazing results so proud
how the [ __ ] are we gonna the mouth is
already kind of good without the [ __ ]
are we gonna do I never realized I don't
have noses Jesus all right let's get rid
of the news
okay nose is gone now let's get a let's
get rid of the eyebrows I am tariff it's
his Voldemort
this is Voldemort skid the eyes needs to
be about six million times larger
Wow he looks so enemy Kauai Cartman
summer
yes that looks look good that looks
natural natural very natural why do they
always have to be so terrifying I never
asked for this
look so real I mean I don't really have
to do much yeah uh the Hat
it looks like [ __ ] is he doing to his
chin
there we go Cartman COO is finish you
rue five hundred percent who should we
do next let's see if we can do Kenny
okay this is so bad but it's the best I
can do alright we're gonna have to take
this overall and make it work I don't
[ __ ] know how can I get a hate that
thing no buts about that bang bang I
have too much energy
okay um it is what it is dad looks great
Wow why did I spend so much time on this
it doesn't even look like it overall
anymore you can tell when I don't try
anymore
Wow wow it's so good let's move on to
the next one
what's the butters butters is my
favorite okay step one the head needs
sweeping like a balloon like that
perfect step to get rid of the ears
there's something magical about the exam
I don't know what it is
Kawai
oh my god the nightmares the nightmares
were all true
hahahaha looks fantastic I love it but
as you look fabulous let's add his
beautiful haircut
you like it betters
okay I'm getting a little lazy here but
uh I do really like the results of
butters I think it's really cute [ __ ]
nightmares right thing
all right pres I'm gonna have to end
that episode there these do take they
take a while the record and I have to go
I'm sorry I wish I could do more but
maybe in another episode leave it like
if you want more of these buzz it's
really fun to do and I know you bros
like them as well so thank you so much
for watching I will see you in the next
one
as always bros stay on shop